My right bulb hasn't been lighted up the last three nights the nightly program runs as normal, but no light. No sound from the ball. Do know what's happening.
Uh, that's not good. So if you're light. If you're right, light isn't lighting up it. I then it's you're not getting the frequencies.
Um, so did the cord get pinched somehow? Did it get pulled out somehow? Is it that plugged in all the way? Do you have it switched to ball? Make sure it's not accidentally switched to that.
Those are the things you want to look at.
Um, you know, the bulbs typically don't burn out, but they can become damaged.
Um, and, you know, you know, most common damages we've seen it just happens to get yanked that, you know, the solder got broken on it.
That will have to go back to true right to be replaced. I can't fix a ball problem.
And, um, you might just need to order a new one from true right.
Um, it's not self-fixible that way. So you can't resold, if you broke the solder, you can't resolder. It has to be a special type of solder and such.
If you're not getting the frequencies, if your bulb is not ready, that's going to work.